Want to master the driven shot? Let's get into it.
So for the driven shot,
you want to approach and direct your shot towards the far corner.
This is because goalkeepers tend to cover the near post.
And if you hit the ball with enough pace,
and they even save it, they might parry it to one of your teammates.
When you go to strike the ball,
you want to plant and face your standing foot
in the direction of the far post
and where you want the ball to go.
Then, with your kicking leg,
you want to hit through the middle of the ball with your laces.
Also, keep your body weight slightly forward
and striking higher up on the ball to keep the shot low. Bosh